all right one of former President Barack
Obama's longest-serving advisors is
offering his strategy to help Democrats
retake the White House dan Pfeiffer was
communications director for the 2008
Obama campaign he held the same role in
the White House before becoming a senior
adviser to the president Pfeiffer's new
book is called yes we still can
politics in the Age of Obama Twitter and
Trump he calls for Democrats to be
audacious authentic and inspirational to
start winning again Dan Pfeiffer is also
co-host of the very popular podcast whoo
God save America good morning good to
have you here good to be here across the
table we're gonna get into some of what
you talk about in the book but first the
big story because you know Gayle is
reporting from the border there on this
immigration issue the Obama
administration also struggled to how to
deal with immigrant families well come
through the border illegally right the
question of immigration and migrants is
something that is one of the great
challenges that every administration has
to deal with how you find the right
balance when your laws and your values
ultimately faced with a crisis like this
we decided not to take this that's that
the Trump administration did because
we're an account trader our values so
simply immoral to separate parents from
kids but the Obama administration
considered it for a brief moment there
was a every idea was up there a Cecilia
Munoz who was our who had led this issue
Aramis said who was on the table for
minutes we looked at it and said there's
no way there's no way we could do this
and we did you're not a fan of the Trump
administration well you see this morning
but but when you see a moment like this
given the position you were in when you
were you guys are in the washing machine
and you would look at the press coverage
you would say gosh they're just totally
getting it wrong do you have any empathy
for the administration as it tries to
get its message out given that you are
often in the same position I have zero
zero empathy for them because they are
but this policy is a perfect example of
what sums up the trouble ministration
which is tremendous cruelty followed by
ranking confidence in dishonesty because
they have offered five explanations for
where this came from if it is their
policy and they believe in it they
should own it and explain it and said
they're lying about it and that's simply
not acceptable from our president dan
what do they know that's what Democrats
do in this moment the president is
trying to pin the blame squarely on
their shoulders there's some legislation
that's going through Congress we
what should Democrats do should they
play ball on this I think ultimately
Democrats need to work with Republicans
to pass immigration what immigration
laws are consistent with our values
committee democratic cars however we
cannot allow the Trump administration to
hold thousands of children hostage as
leverage to get funding for the wall so
they need to do what they've been doing
with the limited levers of power we have
go to these centers demand to see them
talk about it fight back against a Trump
administration be unified and tough and
they have a bill in the Senate and I
think they should demand a vote on that
and if the if Paul Ryan in the house put
a bill to end this policy on the floor
of the house it would get 300 votes you
need to do that
you say you want Democrats to work with
the Republicans to create an immigration
program in keeping with our values but
don't you believe from your experience
and from what you've witnessed because I
think I've heard you say that basically
you don't believe Republicans will be
allowed to by their voters so is what
you're talking about a bipartisan
immigration reform is that even possible
in given your view of politics today it
may not be but it is Paul Ryan Mitch
McConnell Donald Trump say they want to
help the dreamers they say they want to
do these things let's let's call it
let's call the cards let let's see what
they're gonna do let's push for it and
if they don't let's let the voters know
that they decided to do damage of these
children to deport the dreamers and let
everyone know but we we should be
willing to look for solutions but we
shouldn't compromise our values to do
that the book you talk about the way
forward for the Democrats who is going
to be the standard-bearer for the party
what's that message gonna be you
actually say the Democrats could learn
something from Trump about his messaging
right Donald Trump did a very good job
of controlling the conversation around
the election everyone had to respond to
Trump the only way even Hillary Clinton
one of the most powerful prominent
figures could get press coverage was to
respond to Trump and so Democrats need
to learn the lessons of how Trump use
social media used media outlets that
were consistent with his ideology to
control the conversation and raise
issues that I think ultimately we need
to tell a story
it is a compelling inspirational
authentic story about where we want to
leave this country and why Trump in the
republics of the wrong people to do it
we have to in 2018 and we do that in
2021 is Obama as President Obama doing
something from behind the scenes in
order to help that process along look as
I understand it he's going to be out
there campaign
for Democrats in the fall I think he'll
have things to say when he's out there
about what the message should be but he
gave us the roadmap as Democrats of what
to do in his farewell speech back in
June or 2017 we need to organize we need
to March and we need to run races
everywhere and that's what we're doing
and if we continue to do the work the
Democrats progressive been doing since
inauguration day if there's the women's
March then I think we'll have success
but it's gonna it's a lot there's a lot
more work to do a lot of interesting
observations in this book dan Pfeiffer
good to see you thank you so much